we're continuing to see the deterioration.
If Donald Trump's ability to think and to
speak
and to sort of turn what's in his brain into
words that other humans can understand.
I mean, I'm almost struggling to explain what
it is that we're seeing because it's so disturbing.
A Donald Trump had another one of these speeches
where even the teleprompter couldn't make
him sound coherent.
We've seen this before.
Take a look at Donald Trump speaking the other
day, slow slurring, sniffing, huffing and
puffing.
Confused, unclear if he even knows what it
is that he's reading off of his teleprompter.
Notice that when the camera's zooms out, he
sort of seems to be strangely leaning on and
clutching the lector and I mean every element
of this audio and video is unusual.
Have budgets.
Since we came into the administration since
the election of 2016 since January 20th of
2017 we have done things with the military
that few people would have thought possible
budgets of 700 billion, 716 billion and now
$738 billion.
Nobody would've thought that that was possible,
but we had them approved by Republicans and
Democrats.
And that money is now building the most advanced
equipment anywhere on earth equipment that
nobody even could have conceived of even two
years ago.
Put aside for a second that nothing he's saying
is true or make sense.
There is much else going on here.
This could be someone who's normally on uppers
coming down or on an off day.
That's one type of possibility.
Uh, this could be continued cognitive decline,
which we've been talking about.
This could just be an exhausted 73 year old
who simply can't keep up with the demands
of being president because he is obese in
terrible shape.
It could be anything, but it's not normal
and it's not good for the country.
And as a reminder, uh, Aaron Rue Parr from
vox posted this video to Twitter.
The deterioration can be hard to notice day
to day.
Uh, when you hear Trump every day, you might
not notice how much he has fallen off in terms
of his speaking abilities.
But look at Trump during his presidential
campaign in 2015 which was already a far cry
from what the guy was 20 years ago, but still
comparatively quick, spry, agile, the opposite
of 2019 Trump
because I don't need anybody's money.
It's nice.
I don't need anybody's money.
I'm using my own money.
I'm not using the lobbyists.
I'm not using donors.
I don't care.
I'm really rich.
I shared that and I said, I, by the way, I'm
not even saying that in a bragging right.
That's the kind of mindset that's the kind
of thinking you need for this.
As a reminder, if a, that is not enough contrast.
Here's the famous incident, the United shades
of America.
God bless the Palestinians and Jerusalem.
Oh, we, which was initially, I guess attributed
to loose dentures, which we later found out
Trump doesn't even wear.
Let us rethink oldest assumptions and open
our hearts and minds to possible and possibilities.
And finally, I asked the leaders of the region,
politically religious, Israeli and Palestinian,
Jewish and Christian and Muslim to join us
in the noble quest for lasting peace.
Thank you.
God bless you.
God bless Israel.
God bless the Palestinians and God bless the
United Church.
Thank you very much.
It's not just the slurring.
Okay.
To be clear, when this happens, Trump seems
not to recognize what he is reading or what
he is saying.
This is very serious stuff.
If you look at a closeup of Donald Trump's
face during some of these incidents, he actually
sort of seems to be chewing on his tongue
or having trouble getting his tongue out of
the way or in a position where it doesn't
hinder his speech.
He's acting almost like he has full on Novacane
from dental work or something.
Very odd.
This is not a joke.
This is not political.
This is just very serious.
The Trump campaign is politicizing it.
They're sending lackeys around to Fox News
to claim that Joe Biden is actually having
cognitive issues.
Now, I covered the Joe Biden stuff last week.
I, as I said, I would be a hypocrite if I
point out when this stuff is going on with
Donald Trump.
I would be a hypocrite if I didn't point it
out when it's happening with Joe Biden, but
Trump's the president, not a candidate for
one of the nominations for president and Trump's
having the same issues, but 10 times over
to two to a significantly greater magnitude.
Checkout Trump, uh, 2020 director of strategic
communications, Mark Lauder on Fox News, just
playing politics and talking about Joe Biden.
Well, unfortunately, I know a lot of people
will say these are gaps, but it's clearly
a problem with Joe Biden.
I mean, he gets about every detail wrong in
a couple of minutes about this war story.
He can't remember who the prime minister of
the of the United Kingdom is.
He couldn't remember what state he was in
a couple of weeks ago.
I mean, these are not gaps.
It is a problem with Joe Biden and it's causing
a lot of Democrats to start to rethink their
front runner.
This is just too serious for, I don't know
what other way I can say it.
Biden might have something going on.
We're talking about it.
It was weird when he seemed to forget President
Obama's name.
It's been weird when he's misstated the state
that he's in or when different things happened
or whatever else the case may be.
Trump has a very public and very visible multi-year
decline of the same type of stuff that we've
seen from Biden, but worse, many times, greater
Trump leaving a signing ceremony without signing
the thing.
He was their desire to sign Trump walking
away from his limo.
He walks off of air force one the limos right
in front of them.
Trump wanders off and has to be physically
pulled back by secret service and redirected
towards his car.
Uh, Trump wondering where Rudy Giuliani is
when Giuliani is sitting directly in front
of them.
Trump saying, we need to find out the oranges
of the investigation almost as if he's now
the citrus detective of some kind rather than
the origins of the investigation.
It's endless.
I could just list these things for an hour.
If you care about the country and recognize
and agree, maybe you don't agree, but if you
agree, you need a cognitively able person
in the Oval Office.
You need to be questioning what it is that
is happening with Donald Trump.
I am open to any and all suggestions as to
what it is that might be going on here and
this was not the only weird thing that happened
over the long Labor Day weekend and that's
what I want to talk about next.